And, of course, this is not difficult to check.
So the first program, definitely that will stop.
It will print out the 3 words and the length of that word, and then it's done.
Second 1? Yes. That goes into an infinite loop, because x starts out as -2,
and while x < -2, it will decrease x.
Now, you might have been a bit nitpicky here by saying,
"Well, there was a certain limit on how large or small variables can get."
Let's assume here that we're working with an integer structure that can get
as small as we need it to be, and just uses up more memory in that case,
and, in that case, this program here will indeed go into an infinite loop.
And now for this 1 here it's very easy to see that it terminates.
It just adds 1 to the -100 here, and then it's done.
So definitely yes. This program will stop.